- Well, that's good.
if you're digesting fast
food on Spirit Airlines,
it's just shit.
It just fucking sucks.
- That's a really good point.
- [Voiceover] Oh, you should tell that
Jack in the Box story.
- There's a...
- [Voiceover] All right,
how do we do this?
- [Voiceover] Fast food place...
Well, we...
(soft upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] Steven Spielberg, this shit.
Bring him in.
- Arizona, with a couple of my...
- [Voiceover] Start over,
get the whole thing.
- We're on a road trip,
it was a long road trip.
- [Voiceover] Calm down, paint a picture.
This is your Jurassic Park.
He's not paying attention, bring him in,
ask him a question, involve him.
- Have you ever been there?
- Where?-
- Arizona, just the state Arizona.
- No.
- [Voiceover] He has
no point of reference.
- I always say Pennsylvania's
the shitty state.
- [Voiceover] You're riffing.
You're going off script.
Get back to the story.
You're never really gonna work this out.
When you told Brittany
the story, it killed.
Why is it not killing?
You are dying up here.
Was Brittany just pretending to laugh?
Was this not even a good story?
Make up an ending, a
disaster, a high-speed chase,
a, I don't know, just tell
him what the story's about.
- Jack in the Box has
better chicken sandwiches
than you'd think.
(both men mumbling)
- You live and you learn, you know.
- Yeah.
- [Voiceover] Right, yeah.
- [Voiceover] Huh, god,
I'm a real good friend.
(soft upbeat music)